mit schafen metall und ordentlich power
rüttel sebastian läge die haut von der
tomate
denn nur so entsteht am ende die perfekt
cremige industrie tomatensoße sebastian
nägel hat ein altes fitnessgerät der
sechziger jahre wiederentdeckt
überflüssigen pfunden wollte man so zu
leibe rücken heute eher eine kuriosität
[Musik]
lassen das fett runter rütteln die
lebensmittelindustrie und so einen trick
wie ganz andere sachen und war für das
liebste gemüse der deutschen tomaten
die sind nicht nur frisch lecker sondern
schmecken auch aus der dose vor allem
zur nudel suppe verarbeitet
doch weil die ledrige haut in der
tomatensoße stört muss er unter nur ist
sie extrem schwer abzusehen so viele
tomaten
[Musik]
wie dosen fabriken große mengen günstig
und zeit sparen schälen das bilder
produktentwickler zeigen dazu hat er die
tomaten ein wenig ein gerät zuerst
braucht lege kochend heißes wasser um
die tomaten abzubringen dem kniff kennt
man auch von zu hause eben habe ich mir
noch das heck von den hüften rütteln
lassen
jetzt kommen die tomaten schale die
fitness maschine wird zum toom machten
riddler umgebaut
sein plan in einer angeschraubten metall
wanne soll die haut maschinell von den
tomaten abgerubbelt werden ob das
funktioniert rein ins kochende wasser
weil sich das fruchtfleisch beim
erhitzen auf den platz die tomaten
schale rundherum auf
[Musik]
wie bei gekochten eiern erleichtert auch
bei heißen tomaten eine bewährte methode
das anschließende schälen eiskalte
abschreckung papa jetzt jacke schon mal
gelöst wird vorkasse bei den richtigen
schock dabei platzt nicht nur die haut
auf die tomaten behalten durch das hitze
und kälte bad auch ihre roter farbe so
ist es perfekt das kann man sehen man
kann schon ein bisschen lösen
was fehlt so selig oder in fabriken
werden große mengen tomaten auf einmal
gestellt
das funktioniert mit maschinen die
vorsichtig die an gelösten hautfetzen
abreiben ohne dass das zarte
fruchtfleisch zerdrückt wird
[Musik]
durch die kleine reisen die oben drauf
sind würden schön gleichmäßig die schale
ab gerüttelt geht schnell effizient und
zack ist die tomate in der dose wenn
sich sebastian da mal nicht täuscht
jetzt kommt der rückt einspielen
[Musik]
doch der oldtimer zickt rum power etwas
anderes oder
schau mal
vorabend
jetzt wieder muskelkraft aber ist gut
für die kalorienverbrennung jetzt
tatsächlich durch das hin und her
rütteln lösen sich die schalen ab und
die rest tomaten bleiben ganz das kann
sich doch sehen lassen
[Musik]
jawohl es hat funktioniert komplette
schales ab jetzt muss die tomate nur in
die dose fertig ein cleverer trick die
ledrigen fetzen sind ab und das ohne
großen aufwand
dies trägt dazu bei dass selbst
geschälte tomaten immer noch sehr
preiswert angeboten werden
doch nicht nur zarte früchte werden
gerüttelt auch härtere kaliber verlieren
auf diese weise ihre haut erdnüsse
cassius oder haselnüsse der rüttel trick
befreit sie von den dünnen häutchen
unter der schale
die würden in brotaufstrichen und müsli
nämlich stören
eine ganze reihe produkte profitiert von
dem künftigen shell prozess ein cleverer
trick der zu einer besseren qualität
unserer lebensmittel beiträgt
[Musik]
wie habt ihr eure tomatensoße am
liebsten cremig stück ich oder sogar mit
haut sagt es uns in den kommentaren und
wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonniert die zdf
besser esser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei clips